[Musique]
ils sont violonistes violoncellistes
altiste deux femmes deux hommes qui
forment le quatuor à cordes de l'armée
de terre basé à satory cette formation
est unique en son genre car elle est la
seule au sein de l'armée les musiciens
sont des militaires ils ont tous été
recrutés par concours a moi la musique
c'est depuis tout petit j'ai des parents
qui sont musiciens voilà j'ai fait des
études d'écriture aussi j'ai étudié en
allemagne je fais des arrangements pour
le quatuor aussi en fait j'ignorais
complètement qu'il y avait des missions
l'armée de terre je savais que la garde
la garde républicaine existait et donc
en fait je savais pas qu'on pouvait à la
fois tenir une arme et un violon dans
les mains
[Musique]
ce quatuor à cordes fait partie du
commandement des musiques de l'armée de
terre
habituellement il se produit pour les
plus hautes autorités civiles et
militaires mais pour mieux les faire
connaître à certaines représentations
sont ouvertes au public une première
le but de cette série de concerts
c'était les faire découvrir
déjà d'une à la population versaillaise
parce que je pense que les versaillais
ne savent pas qu'il y ait un quatuor
dans leur ville de leur montrer aussi
que nos musiciens militaires peuvent
jouer bien évidemment du répertoire
classique le quatuor américain de dvorak
mais d'ubs et off du hyde en fait ils
peuvent ils peuvent tous jouer
après la musique américaine les
prochains moments musicaux du quatuor à
cordes seront consacrés aux musiques
d'halloween ou encore de noël
quarante minutes de concert qui demande
une préparation quotidienne
nous devons être présents à la caserne
de 8h à 17h ton commence à répéter tous
ensemble vers 10h à peu près voilà et
ensuite de l'après midi on alterne entre
travail personnel et répétitions à 4 en
fonction du programme qu'on a monté des
concerts qu'on a à faire
l'auditorium peut accueillir jusqu'à 80
personnes pour découvrir le quatuor à
cordes de l'armée terre il suffit de
s'inscrire prochain rendez vous les 7 et
27 novembre
[Applaudissements]